that's short like like long
introductions are no good um Sam knows
uh all right ready everybody I'm not
going to ask if the mic is working like
in every talk so far um I'll just assume
it's working I mean no [ __ ]
[Applause]
all right well make it work somebody all
right so this is like some kind of class
tradition um all right all right I wrote
out my talk and afterwards in a couple
days I will like turn it from a talk
into an essay and put it online so you
don't have to take notes just just
listen all right so one of the
advantages of having kids is that when
you have to give advice to people you
can ask yourself what would I tell my
own kids and actually you find this
really focus of you um so even though my
kids are little my two-year-old today
when asked what he was going to be after
- you said a bat the correct answer was
three but a bat is so much more
interesting so even though my kids are
little I already know what I would tell
them about startups if they were in
college and so that is what I'm going to
tell you so you're literally getting
what I would give my own kids most of
you are young enough to be my own kids
all right so startups are very
counterintuitive and I'm not sure
exactly why it could be simply because
knowledge about them has not permeated
our culture yet but whatever the reason
this is an area where you cannot trust
your intuitions all the time it's like
skiing in that way any of you guys learn
to ski as adults you know when you're
skiing when you first try skiing and you
want to slow down your first impulse is
to lean back just like in everything
else but lean back on skis and you fly
down the hill out of control so as I
learned so part of learning to ski just
learning to suppress that impulse
eventually you get new habits but in the
beginning there's this list of things
you're trying to remember as you start
down the hill you know like alternate
feet make F turns do not drag the inside
foot all this stuff well startups are as
naturalist skiing and there is a similar
list and stuff you have to remember for
startups and what I'm going to give you
today is the beginning of the list the
list of the counterintuitive stuff you
have to remember to like prevent your
existing instincts from leading you
astray the first thing on it is the fact
I just mentioned that startups are so
weird that if you follow your instincts
they will lead you astray if you
remember nothing more than that when
you're about to make a mistake you may
at least pause before making it when I
was running Y Combinator we used to joke
that our function was to tell founders
things they would ignore and it's really
true batch after batch the YC partners
Warren founders about mistakes they are
about to make and the founders ignore
them and they come back a year later and
say I wish we'd listened but that dude
is in their cap table there's nothing
they can do um why the founders
persistently ignore the partners advice
well the thing about counterintuitive
ideas they contradict your intuitions so
they seem wrong so of course your first
impulse to ignore that is to ignore them
and in fact that is not just the curse
of Y Combinator but to some extent our
raison d'être you don't need people to
give you advice it doesn't surprise you
right this founders existing intuitions
gave them the right answers they
wouldn't need us that's why there are a
lot of ski instructors and not many
running instructors right like that you
don't see those two words together
running instructor as much as you see
ski instructor
um it's because skiing is
counterintuitive so sort of what um what
YC is is like business ski instructors
except for going up slopes instead of
down them um well ideally you can
however trust your instincts about
people you your life so far hasn't been
much like starting a start-up but all
the interactions you've had with people
are just like the interactions you have
with people in the business world so in
fact one of the big mistakes that
founders make is not to trust their
intuitions about people enough they meet
someone who
seems impressive but about whom they
feel some misgivings and then later when
things blow up they tell them they say
you know I knew there was something
wrong about that guy but I ignored it
because he seemed so impressive um and
there's this a specific sub case in
business especially if you have come
from an engineering background as I
believe you all do you think business is
supposed to be this sort of slightly
distasteful thing and so when you meet
people who seem smart but somehow
distasteful you think well okay this
must be normal for business it's not
just like pick people the way you would
pick people if you were picking friends
um this is one of those rare cases where
it works to be self-indulgent work with
people you genuinely like in respect and
that you have known long enough to be
sure because there's a lot of people who
are really good at seeming likeable for
a while um just wait till your interests
are opposed and then you'll see all
right um the second counterintuitive
point is that and this will might come
as a little bit of a disappointment but
what you need to succeed in a startup is
not expertise in startup that makes this
class different from most other classes
you take you take a French class at the
end of it you will learn how to speak
French you do the work you may not sound
exactly like a French person but pretty
close right um this class can teach you
about startups but that is not what you
need to know what you need to know to
succeed in a startup is not expertise in
startups
what you need is expertise in your own
users Mark Zuckerberg did not succeed in
Facebook because he was an expert in
startups he succeeded despite being a
complete noob at startups I mean
Facebook was first incorporated as a
Florida LLC even you guys know better
than that um
he succeeded despite being a complete
noob it startups because he understood
his users very well most of you don't
know the mechanics of raising an angel
around right and if you feel bad about
that don't because I can tell you Mark
Zuckerberg probably doesn't know the
mechanics of raising on an angel round
either if he was even paying attention
when Ron Conway wrote him the big check
um he has probably forgotten about it by
now
in fact I worry it's not merely
unnecessary for people to learn in
detail about the mechanics of starting a
start-up but possibly somewhat dangerous
because another of the characteristic
mistakes of young founders starting
startup is to go through the motions of
starting a start-up they come up with
some plausible sounding idea they raise
funding at a nice valuation they rent a
nice office in Soma hire a bunch of
their friends and then the next step
after
[Music]
rent a nice office in Soma and hire a
bunch of their friends is gradually
realize how completely [ __ ] they are
because while imitating all the outward
forms and starting a startup they have
neglected the one thing that's actually
essential which is to make something
people want by the way that's the only
use of that square word except for the
initial one that was involuntary um and
I did check the Sam whether it would be
okay um he said he had done it several
times I mean use the word
we saw this happen so often no I mean
people going through the motions and
starting a startup but we made up a name
for it playing house
eventually I realized why it was
happening the reason young founders go
through the motions of starting a
startup is because that is what they
have been trained to do for their whole
lives up to this point
think about what it takes to get into
college extracurricular activities check
right um even in college classes most of
the work you do is as artificial as
running laps and I am NOT attacking the
educational system for being this way
but inevitably the work that you do to
learn something is going to have some
amount of fakeness to it and if you
measure people with performance they
will inevitably exploit the difference
to the degree that what you're measuring
is largely an artifact of the fakeness
and I confess that I did this myself in
college in fact here is a useful tip on
getting good grades I found and in a lot
of classes there might only be 20 or 30
ideas that actually had the right shape
to make good exam questions and so the
way I studied for exams in these classes
was not to master the material in the
class but to try and figure out what the
exam questions would be and work out the
answers in advance unlike for me the
test was not like what my answers would
be on the exam for me the test was which
of my exam questions would turn up on
the exam okay so I would I would get my
grade instantly I would walk into the
exam and look at the questions and see
how many I got right essentially
it works in a lot of classes especially
CF classes I'm automata theory there's
only a few things that make sense to ask
about automata theory um so it's not
surprising that after being effectively
trained for their whole life to play
such games young founders first impulse
I'm starting a startup is to figure out
what the tricks are for this new game
what are the extracurricular activities
have starts what are the things I have
to do they always want to know since
since apparently the measure of success
for a start-up is fundraising another
noob mistake they always want to know
what are the tricks for convincing
investors and we have to tell them the
best way to convince investors is to
start a startup that's actually doing
well meaning growing fast and then
simply tell investors so um so then they
are okay what are the tricks for growing
fast right and this is exacerbated by
the existence of this term growth hacks
right whenever you hear anybody talk
about growth hacks just mentally
translate it in your mind into [ __ ]
because what we tell them is the way to
make your startup grow is to make
something that users really love right
and then tell them about it
so that's what you have to do that's
growth hacks right there um so so many
of the conversations the YC partners
have with the founders begin with the
founders saying a sentence that begins
with how do I and the partner is
answering with the sentence that begins
with just right why do they make things
so complicated the reason I realized
after years of being puzzled by this is
they're looking for the trick they've
been trained to look for the trick so
this is the third thing the third
counterintuitive thing to remember about
startup starting a startup is where
gaming the system stops working gaming
the system may continue to work if you
go to work for a big company depending
on how broken the company is you may be
able to succeed by sucking up to the
right person giving the impression of
productivity by sending emails late at
night
or if you're smart enough changing a
clock on your computer because who's
going to check the headers right but I
like an audience but I can tell jokes
like that to you and they left over in
the business school headers okay god
this thing is being recorded I just
realized that all right from now on we
are sticking strictly to the script
all right um what in startup that does
not work there is no boss to trick
there's no how can you trick people if
there's no one to trick there's only
users and all users care about um is
that is whether your software does what
they want right they're like sharks
sharks are like too stupid to fool you
can't like wave a red flag at a shark
and fluid it's like meat or no meat um
so you have to have something people
want and you only prosper to the extent
that you do a dangerous thing is
particularly for you guys the dangerous
thing is if faking does work to some
extent with investors you if you're
really good at knowing what you're
talking about you can fool investors for
one maybe two rounds of funding but it's
not in your interest to I mean you're
all doing this for equity you're playing
a confidence trick on yourself you can
wasting your own time because the
startup is doomed and all you're doing
is you're just going to waste your time
writing it down
um so stop looking for the trick there
are tricks and startups as there are in
any domain but they are an order of
magnitude less important in solving the
real problem someone who knows zero
about fundraising but has made something
users really love will have an easier
time raising money than someone who
knows every trick in the book but has a
flat usage graph um though in a sense
it's bad news that gaming the startup
stops works gaming system stops working
now um in the sense that you're deprived
of one of your most powerful weapons and
after all something you have spent 20
years mastering um it is something I
find it very exciting the that there
even exists parts of the world where
taming the system is not how you win
I would have been really excited in
college if I had explicitly realized
that there are parts of the world where
gaming the system matters less than
others and some where it hardly matters
at all but there are and this is one of
the most important things to think about
when you're planning your future um okay
um how do you win at each type of work
and what do you want to win by doing so
um that brings us to our fourth
counterintuitive point startups are
all-consuming if you start a startup it
will take over your life to a degree
that you cannot imagine um and if it
succeeds it will take over your life for
a long time for several years very least
maybe a decade maybe the rest of your
working life so there's a real
opportunity cost here it may seem to you
that Larry Page has an enviable life
that there are parts of it they are
definitely unenviable the way the world
looks to him is that he started running
as fast as he could at age 25 and he is
not stopped to catch his breath since
every day [ __ ] happens within the Google
Empire that only the Emperor can deal
with and he as the emperor has to deal
with it if he goes on vacation for even
a week a whole backlog of [ __ ]
accumulates and he has to bear this
uncomplainingly because number one as
the company's daddy he can never show
fear or weakness number two if you're a
billionaire you get zero actually less
than zero sympathy if you complain about
having a difficult wife
which has this strange side effect that
the difficulty of being a successful
startup founder is concealed from almost
everyone who's done it people who win
the hundred meters in the Olympics like
they walk up to them and are going like
right it's like Larry Page is doing that
too but you never get to see it um all
right where are we Y Combinator has now
funded several companies that could be
called big successes um and in every
single case the founders say the same
thing it never gets any easier the
nature of the problems change so you may
be you may be worrying about more
glamorous problems like construction
delays in your new London offices rather
than the broken air conditioner in your
studio apartment but the total volume of
worry never decreases if anything it
increases starting a successful startup
is similar to having kids and that it's
like a button you press that changes
your life irrevocably um and while it is
like honestly the best thing in the
world having kids if you take away one
thing from this lecture remember that um
there are a lot of things that are
easier to do after you before you have
kids then after many of which will make
you a better parent when you do have
kids and so in rich countries most
people delay pushing the button for a
while and I'm sure you are all
intimately familiar with that procedure
um yet when it comes to starting
startups a lot of people seem to think
they're supposed to start them in
college are you crazy
and what are the universities thinking
they go out of their way to ensure that
their students are well supplied with
contraceptives and yet they are starting
up entrepreneurship programs and startup
incubators left and right to be fair the
universities have their hand forced here
a lot of incoming students are
interested in startups universities are
at least de-facto supposed to prepare
you for your career and so if you're
interested in startups it seems like
universities are supposed to teach you
about startups and if they don't maybe
they lose applicants to universities you
do claim to do that so can universities
teach you about startups
not what are we doing here um yes and no
as I explained they can teach you about
startups but this is not what you need
to know essentially what universe if you
want to learn French universities can
teach you linguistics that's what this
is this is a linguistics class right
we're teaching you about how to learn
languages and what you need to know is
like how to learn a particular language
um what you need to know are the needs
of your own users you can't learn those
until you actually start the company um
and starting a company which means it's
starting a start-up is something and you
can intrinsically only learn by doing it
and you can't do that in college for the
reason I just explained it startups take
over your entire life if you start a
start-up in college if you start up
startup as a student you can't start a
startup as a student because if you
start a startup you're not a student
anymore you may be nominally a student
but you won't even be that for much
longer
so given this dichotomy which of the two
paths should you take be a real student
and not start a startup or start a real
startup and not be a student well I can
answer that one for you I'm talking to
my own kids here do not start a start-up
in college huh I hope I'm not just
pointing anyone seriously honestly um
starting a startup could be a component
of a good life for a lot of ambitious
people but this is just part of a much
bigger problem that you're trying to
solve how to have a good life right and
those starting a startup could be a good
thing to do at some point 20 is not the
optimal time to do it there are things
that that you can't there are things you
can do in your early 20s that you cannot
do as well before or after like plunge
deeply into projects on a whim that seem
that like they'll have no payoff um or
travel super cheaply with no sense of a
deadline in fact those are really just
isomorphic shapes and different domains
for unambitious people this sort of
thing can be the dreaded failure to
launch but for the ambitious one it's a
really valuable sort of exploration and
if you start a start-up at 20 and you're
sufficiently successful you will never
get to do it
Mark Zuckerberg will never get to bum
around a foreign country
he can if he goes to a foreign country
it's either as a defective state visit
or like he's hiding out incognito at the
gorge the gorge sank in Paris right um
but he's never going to get to just like
backpack around Thailand if that's still
what people do um people still backpack
around Thailand okay well there's just
the first real sign of enthusiasm I
feasible I should have given this talk
in Thailand all right he can do things
that you can't do like chartered jet to
fly him to foreign countries really big
jet um but success has taken a lot of
the serendipity out of his life he
Facebook is running him as much as he's
running Facebook and while it can be
really cool to be in the grip of some
project you consider your life's work um
there are advantages to serendipity and
among other things it gives you more
options to choose your life's work from
there's not even a trade-off here you're
not sacrificing anything if you forego
starting a start-up at 20 because you'll
be more likely to succeed if you wait in
the unlikely case you're 20 like
astronomically unlikely case that you're
20 and you have some side project that
takes takes off like Facebook did then
you face a choice of either running with
it or not and maybe it's reasonable to
run with it but usually the way startups
take off is for the founders to make
them take off and it's gratuitous we
stupid to do that at 20 so should you do
it in any age I realized I've made
starting a startup sound kind of hard if
I haven't let me try again starting a
startup is really hard what if it's too
hard what if you're not up to this
challenge the answer is the fifth
counterintuitive point you can't tell
your life so far has given you some idea
what your prospects might be if you
wanted to become a mathematician or a
professional football player um boy it's
not every audience you could say that to
but unless you have had a very strange
life indeed
you have not done much it's like
starting a startup meaning starting a
startup will change you a lot if it
works out so what you're trying to
estimate is not just what you are but
what you could become and who can do
that well not me for the last nine years
it was my job to try and guess whether
people would guess what I wrote predict
in here and it came out of guess um
that's a very informative Freudian flip
seriously
it's easy to tell how smart people are
in ten minutes
you know hit a few tennis balls over the
net and do they hit them back at you or
into the net um but the hard part was
and the most important part was
predicting how tough and ambitious they
would become there may be no one at this
point who has more experience than me of
doing this and I can tell you how much
an expert can know about that the answer
is not much I learned from experience to
keep a completely open mind about which
startup in each batch which startups
would turn out to be the Stars the
founders sometimes thought they knew
some arrived feeling confident that they
would ace Y Combinator just as they had
aced every one of the few easy
artificial tests they had faced in life
so far others arrived wondering what
mistake had caused them to be admitted
and hoping that no one would discover it
um but there is little to no at its no
correlation between these attitudes and
how things turn out I've read the same
is true in the military that the
swaggering recruits are no more likely
to turn out to be really tough than the
quiet ones and probably for the same
reason that the tests are so different
from the tests and people's previous
live if you're absolutely terrified of
starting a startup you probably
shouldn't do it unless you're one of
those people who gets off on doing
things you're afraid of otherwise if
you're merely unsure of whether you're
going to be able to do it
the only way to find out is to try just
not now
so if you want to start up one day if
you want to start a start up one day
what do you do now in college there are
only two things you need initially an
idea and co-founders and the mo for
getting them both is the same which
leads to our sixth sixth and last
counterintuitive point um the way to get
startup ideas is not to try to think of
startup ideas I've written a whole essay
on this and I'm not going to repeat the
whole thing here but the short version
is that if you make a conscious effort
to try and think of startup ideas you
will I think of ideas that are not only
bad but bad and plausible sounding
meaning you and everybody else will be
fooled by them and you'll waste a lot of
time before realizing they're no good
the way to come up with good startup
ideas is to take a step back instead of
trying to make a conscious effort to
think of startup ideas turn your brain
into the type that has start-up ideas
unconsciously in fact so unconsciously
that you don't even realize it first
that their startup ideas this is not
only possible Yahoo Google Facebook and
Apple all got started this way none of
these companies were even supposed to be
companies at first they were all just
side projects the very best ideas almost
have to start a side project because
they're always such outliers that your
conscious mind would reject them as
ideas for companies okay so how do you
turn your mind into the kind that has
startup ideas unconsciously one learn a
lot about things that matter to work on
problems that interest you three with
people you like and respect that third
part incidentally is how you get
co-founders at the same time as the idea
the first time I wrote that paragraph
instead of learn a lot about things that
matter
I wrote become good at some technology
but that prescription those sufficient
is too narrow what was special about
Brian Chesky and Joe Gebbia
from Airbnb was not that they were
experts in technology with art school
they were experts in design and perhaps
even more importantly they were really
good at organizing people and getting
projects done um so you don't have to
work on technology per se so long as you
work on things that stretch you what
kind of things are those now that very
hard to answer in the general case
history is full of examples of young
people who are working on problems that
no one else at the time thought were
important and in particular that their
parents didn't think they were important
on the other hand history is even fuller
of k of examples of parents who sought
their kids we're wasting their time and
who were right so how do you know if
you're working on real stuff I mean when
twitch TV switched from being justin TV
to swift twitch TV and they were going
to broadcast people playing video games
how it's like what but turned out to be
a good business oh well I know I know
how I know real problems are interesting
and I'm self-indulgent I like I'm always
interested in working on interesting
things even if no one else cares about
them and I find it very hard to make
myself work on boring things even if
they're supposed to be important my life
is full of case after case where I
worked on things just because I was
interested and they turned out to be
useful later in some worldly way Y
Combinator itself is something I only
did because it seemed interesting so I
seem to have some sort of internal
compass that helped me out but this is
for you not me and I don't know what you
have in your head maybe if I think more
about it I could come up with some
heuristics for recognizing genuinely
interesting ideas but for now all I can
give you is the hopelessly question
begging advice incidentally this is the
actual meaning of the phrase begging the
question the hopelessly question begging
advice that if you're interested in
genuinely interesting problems
gratifying your interest energetically
is the best way to prepare yourself for
a start-up and for that matter probably
the best way to live but although I
can't explain in the general case what
counts as an interesting problem I can
tell you about a large sub
if you think of technology as something
that's spreading like a sort of fractal
stain every point on the edge that's
moving represents an interesting problem
steam engines not so much although maybe
you never know
so one guaranteed way to turn your mind
into the type that start-up ideas form
in unconsciously is to get yourself to
the leading edge of some technology to
to as Paul Buchheit put it live in the
future
and when you get there ideas that seem
uncannily prescient to other people will
seem obvious to you you may not realize
they're startup ideas but you'll know
there's something that ought to exist
for example back at Harvard back in the
mid 90s a fellow grad student of my
friends Robert and Trevor wrote his own
voice over IP software um it wasn't
meant to be a startup he never tried to
turn it into one he just wanted to talk
to his girlfriend in Taiwan without
paying for long distance call um and
since he was an expert on networks it
seemed obvious to him that the thing to
do was turn the sound into packets and
ship them over the internet for free why
didn't everybody do this those weren't
good at writing that kind of software um
he never did anything with this he never
tried to turn it into a startup but that
is how all the best startups tend to
happen um so strangely enough the
optimal thing to do in college if you
want to be a successful startup founder
is not some sort of new vocational
version of college focused on
entrepreneurship
it's the classic version of college
education for its own sake if you want
to start a startup what you should do in
college is learn powerful things and if
you have genuine intellectual curiosity
that's what you'll naturally tend to do
if you just follow your own inclinations
the component of entrepreneurship can
ever quite say that word with a straight
face um that really matters is domain
expertise Larry Page is Larry Page
because he was an expert on search and
the way he became an expert on search
was because he was genuinely interested
in it not because of some ulterior
motive
at its best starting a startup is merely
an ulterior motive for curiosity and
you'll do it best if you introduce the
ulterior motive at the end of the
process so here is the ultimate advice
for young would-be startup founders
reduced to two words just learn all
right how much time do we have left 18
minutes of questions good god um do you
guys have the question
sure we'll start with two persons on
organ disturb I do that you're in charge
whatever you want to do okay so to start
with online and the most voted question
today why length or feedom by the way
we'll talk to the non-technical founder
most affected regions user
how can a non-technical founder most
effectively contribute to a startup well
if the startup is if the startup is
working in some domain if it's not a
pure technology startup but it's working
in some very specific domain like if
it's uber right and then the
non-technical founder was an expert in
the limo business then actually the
non-technical founder are probably doing
most of the work recruiting drivers and
doing whatever else
uber has to do right and the technical
founder will be just writing the iPhone
app which is promptly less well iPhone
and Android app which is less than half
of it if it's a purely technology
startup the the non-technical founder
does sales and brings coffee and
cheeseburgers to the programmer okay
how audience okay audience yeah do you
see any value in physical for people who
want to entrepreneurship do I see any
value in hope we probably won't have to
guess the second question which I
suppose is the answer here first
question
okay the question is is there any value
in business school if you're interested
in entrepreneurship and if so what
so basically no I mean it sounds
undiplomatic but the point is what
Business School was designed for is to
teach people management right and
management is a problem that you only
have in a start-up if you're
sufficiently successful so really what
you need to what you need to know early
on to make a startup successful is
developing products you'd be better off
going to design school um if you want to
go to some sort of school although
frankly the way to learn how to do it is
just to do it you know one of the things
I got wrong early on is that I advised
people who were interested in starting a
startup to go work for some other
company for a few years before starting
their own but honestly the best way to
learn how to start a start-up is just to
try and start it you may not be
successful but you'll learn faster if
you just do it so not really
business schools are trying really hard
to do this but honestly like they were
they were designed to train the officer
corps of large companies right which is
what business seemed to be back when it
was a choice of either the officer corps
of large companies or joe's shoe store
and then there was this new thing Apple
which started out as small as Joe's shoe
store and then like turns into this
giant mega company but they weren't
designed for that world and like let's
they're good at what they're good at
they should just do that and screw this
whole entrepreneurship thing just
because it's cool yeah yeah what about
those first people at Saturday entire
match okay so management is a problem
only if you're successful what about
those first two or three people well
ideally you're successful before you
even hire two or three people right um
didn't you say Sam that Airbnb took five
months to hire their first employee so
ideally you don't have even two or three
people for quite a while when you do you
can you can sort of the first hire is in
a startup
are almost like founders they should be
motivated by the same things they can't
be people they can't be people you have
to like manage right this is like that
this is not like the office or something
like that these are your these have to
be your peers really um you shouldn't
have to manage them much no way oh well
never City never how the could repeat
all these questions so if someone has to
manage no way they should be on the
founding team in the case where you're
doing something where you need some sort
of super advanced technical thing and
there's some boffin if you know that
word who knows this thing and nothing
else in the world including like how to
wipe his mouth um then it may be to your
advantage to hire said boffin and wipe
his mouth for him um but as a general
rule you want people who are um sort of
self-motivated early on they should be
just like founders yeah questions in the
far back recurrent in a bubble do I
think we're currently in a bubble um
okay so I'll give you two answers to
this question uh one ask me questions
they're useful to this audience because
these people are here to learn how to
start startups and I have in my head
like more data about that than anybody
else and you're asking me the kind of
questions a reporter does because they
can't think of anything interesting to
ask um but I will answer your question
um there is a difference between prices
merely being high and a bubble a bubble
is a very specific form of prices being
high where people knowingly pay high
prices for something in the hope that
they will be able to unload it later on
some greater fool right and that's what
happened in the late 90s like in VCS
knowingly invested in [ __ ] startups
thinking that they would be able to take
those things public and unload them on
the retail investors before everything
blew up and I was there oh therefore
that at the epicenter of it all and that
is not what's happening today prices are
high valuations are high but valuations
being
does not mean a bubble every every
commodity has prices to go up and down
in some sort of sine wave definitely
prices are high and so we tell people if
you raise money don't think the next
time you raise money it's going to be so
easy you know maybe between now and then
the Chinese economy will have exploded
and there's another giant disasterous
recession who knows assume the worst
um but bubble no yes I'm noticing in
friends among young people and
successful owners within one start one
word trade company they want to start
like 20 and so you're trying to the rise
of you lap attendants where they're
going to try to lots of Russian stuff I
don't know really celery now yeah but
you like ideal might knowledge like you
don't like IQ labs like you're asking
100 yeah yeah okay so there's this new
thing where people start labs that are
supposed to spin-off startup um it might
work that's how Twitter started in fact
I meant idea lab not idea that was
another Freudian slip because Twitter
was not Twitter at first Twitter with
the side project side project at a
company called idea that was supposed to
be in the podcasting business you're
like podcasting business to those words
even grammatically fit together the
answer turned out to be no as Evan
discovered um but like as a side project
they spun off Twitter and boy with that
dog wagging tail um so people are
starting these things that are supposed
to spin-off startups will at work
quite possibly quite possibly if the
right people do it um you can't do it
yet though because you have to do with
your own money
um yeah far back and I hate to step in
this room a gendered football but what
it might you have seen under this is
very cleansing female co-founders when
you're pursuing funding well it probably
is true that women have a harder time
raising money right I've noticed this
empirically and Jessica's just about to
publish a bunch of interviews with
female founders and a lot of them said
that they thought they had a hard time a
harder time raising money to
um so what I would remember what I said
like the way to raise money make your
startup actually do well well that's
just especially true in that case if you
have any if you if you miss the ideal
target from the VCS point of view in any
respect the way to solve that problem is
make the startup to you really well so
in fact there was a point like a year or
two ago when I tweeted this growth graph
of this company and I didn't say who
they were but I knew it would start
people asking and it was actually a
female founded startup that was having
trouble raising money but their growth
graphs are stupendous and so I tweeted
it knowing it was like home because VCS
would start asking me cool is that right
I'm like growth graphs have no gender
right so if they see the growth graph
first let them fall in love with that
right um so do well which is good advice
for startups generally yeah what what
what was you going what would I learn in
college
mmm-hmm literary theory no just kidding
hum well you know honestly I think I
might try and study physics I feel that
the thing I feel like I missed for some
reason like I was all excited can when I
was a kid
computers were that thing maybe they
still are right so I sort of got very
excited about writing code and you can
do things you can do we could write real
programs in your bedroom you can't like
build real linear accelerators on maybe
you can um so maybe maybe physics I feel
can I always sort of look at why I
noticed I sort of look longingly it's
physics um so maybe but I don't know if
that's what am I saying I'm saying I was
about to say I don't know if that's
going to be helpful starting a start-up
I just told you to follow your curiosity
who cares if it's helpful it'll turn out
to be helpful questions where you're
referring success in your work and first
all i-78 you efficient ah boy okay so
what are my recurring systems in my work
and personal life that makes me
efficient well having kids is a good way
to be efficient because you have no time
left
so if you want to get anything done the
amount of done you do per time is high
so actually many parents many startup
founders who have kids have made that
point explicitly it causes you to focus
because you have no choice
ah let's see but that's now I wouldn't
actually recommend having kids just to
make you more so let's see um you know I
don't think I'm very efficient I have
two ways of getting work done one is
like during Y Combinator the way I
worked on Y Combinator is I was forced
to write like here there were just an
apple I had to set the application
deadline and then people would apply and
then there were all these applications
that I had to respond to you by a
certain time so I had to read them and I
knew if I read them badly we would get
bad startup so I tried really hard to
read them well right so I set up this
situation that forced me to work the
other kind of work I do is like writing
essays and I do that involuntarily I'm
like walking down the street and the
essay starts writing itself in my head
and so really I either force myself to
work on less exciting things or the why
can't help working on exciting things
and I don't I don't have any useful
techniques for making myself efficient
sorry
um if you work on things you like you
don't have to force yourself to be
official yeah when is a good time to
turn a side project into a startup you
will know right it starts you use when
you okay so the question is when do you
turn a start-up into a side project into
a real startup you will know that it's
becoming a real startup when it takes
over an alarming percentage of your life
right like when you find like my god
I've just spent all day working on this
thing that supposed to be a side project
I'm going to fail all my classes what am
I going to do right um then maybe it's
turning into a startup yes wait I
already answered your question I should
ask I should let somebody else after I
may get back to you yeah
you'll know when you started to do
extremely well but I feel like in a lot
of cases it is a little bit gray line
where like you know you have some users
but maybe not is explosive bill charging
up to the right
how will you do or what would you
recommend doing in doses for a change in
your outpatient time reasons how do you
Johnson
okay when I start up this sort of
growing but not much um didn't you tell
them they were supposed to reduce things
that don't scale you sir have not done
the reading you are plus vis therefore
because I wrote a whole essay an answer
to that question and that is if do
things that don't scale so just go read
that because I can't remember everything
I said but about exactly that problem
yes back there henna startup should not
go through a few Bayesian European what
kind of tea mean give me my attention
Ella why key no I fear what kind of
startup should not go through YC um
definitely any that will fail and or if
you'll succeed but you're an intolerable
intolerable person that also Sam would
probably sooner do without um short of
that I cannot think of any because a
large percentage founders are often
surprised by how large a percentage of
the problems that startups have are the
same regardless of what type of thing
they're working on and those tend to be
the kind of problem that wifey helps
with the most not the ones that are
domain-specific so I can't is there a
G's can you think it's a class of
startup the YC wouldn't work for I can't
I mean we had like fission and fusion
startups in the last batch or the they
had um yes I mention that it's good like
if you learn a lot of something that
matters yes good size yeah what matters
well if you think it's okay so how do
you figure out what matters
um if you think of technology it's
something that's spreading is a sort of
fractal stain anything on the edge
represents an interesting idea sounds
familiar
um so how do you figure out um like I
said that was the problem you have
correctly identified the thing where I
didn't really answer the question where
I gave this question begging answer I
said like die
like I'm interested in interesting
things if you're interested in
interesting things work on them and
things will all work out right but how
do you tell what is it real problem I
don't know
that's like important enough to write a
whole essay about and I don't know the
answer I probably should write something
about that I don't know I don't know I
figured out a technique for detecting
whether you have a taste for genuinely
interesting problems which is whether
you find working on boring things
intolerable right and there are known
boring things like literary theory and
working in middle management in some
large company so if you could tolerate
those things then you must not you must
either have stupendous self discipline
or you don't have a taste for genuinely
interesting problems and vice versa yeah
okay one more question it better be good
I was burning up like a shot like a
funnel map chat what do I know about
snapchat we didn't fund them okay how
about another question alright go ahead
but if I can raise a lot of culture
there are a lot of that but vehicles are
funny real at the blind spots but
alright okay so if you hire people you
like you might get a monoculture and how
do you deal with the blind spots that
arise um starting a startup is something
where many things will be going wrong
you can't expect it to be perfect and
the advantages of hiring people that you
know and like are far greater than the
we know this small disadvantage of it
disadvantages of having some monoculture
you look at it empirically all the most
successful startups someone just like
hires all their pals out of college
all right you guys thank you
[Applause]
you